in california they did something really
sneaky they put this curriculum
into the anti-bullying curriculum so
usually you would think this would go
into the sex ed curriculum which parents
are allowed to opt out of
but they put it into the anti-bullying
curriculum under the pretext that you
couldn't possibly police bullying unless
you taught every child
that only they know their true gender
and of course we know that's
nonsense because you you can absolutely
police bullying and should police
bullying
against sexual minorities and every
other student without
introducing everybody to a to a
false ideology
but so chapter five is about the schools
and i i think this is kind of
fascinating because we've sort of just
watched
intellectual rot run across all of our
schools and you you just have to kind of
go with whatever
the thing of the day is
um how much of this is just sort of
being taught
at public schools do you think i know it
depends what state you're in but here we
are
both in cali so in california or worse
right it's very extreme in this state so
it gender identity education is
something you can't opt out of it begins
in kindergarten
and it's really extreme we start by
teaching you know five-year-olds that
whatever however they were born a doctor
just made a guess and only they know
their true gender
and this doesn't push kids to transition
necessarily but what it does do is the
moment these
young girls in particular hit
adolescence they go through a period
where they hate their own bodies they
feel ugly this is something nearly every
woman
can attest to um the the solution
readily leaps to mind because it's
something they've learned about for
years
and and it's that oh my gosh i know why
i'm so uncomfortable in my body it's
because i'm supposed to be a boy
were you able to figure out at all how
these bad ideas get so influential
at all the schools seemingly all the
schools at least in california but
but new york too and all over the
country just how infectious the ideas
are
right so i was a little bit because i
was able to get a lot of documents out
of the california teachers association
concerned teachers send them sent them
to be uh
sent them to me and um there are
there's really no division in california
between the activists
and the teachers activists are not only
training the teachers
they are providing all the curriculum
for you know gender identity and sexual
orientation education
so it's coming from very extreme sources
and in teachers who are a little
uncomfortable about it
are completely intimidated into silence
so when you say that at five years old
they're they're taught this
um for the average parent that might go
into that school and say well i don't
want my child hearing that at five years
old which no five-year-old it has
nothing to do with even what's true or
not
no five-year-old can comprehend this
stuff that that in
in effect that person is going to be
blacklisted and
god only knows what they'll do to the
poor kid that's right
um you can't because in california they
did something really sneaky
they put this curriculum into the
anti-bullying curriculum
so usually you would think this would go
into the sex ed curriculum
which parents are allowed to opt out of
but they put it into the anti-bullying
curriculum
under the pretext that you couldn't
possibly police bullying unless you
taught every child
that only they know their true gender
and of course we know that's
nonsense because you you can absolutely
police bullying and should police
bullying
against sexual minorities and every
other student without
introducing everybody to a to a
false ideology yeah do you have any
numbers on what percentage of the public
school teachers
like actually buy it versus who's just
going along i guess that would be hard
to quantify
it's it's very hard public schools
teachers are terrified i have
i spoke to one teacher who posted
something on social media it was very
tame she said i don't know this seems to
be confusing a lot of kids at my school
effectively and she was suspended
immediately and this was on her private
um
facebook page so teachers are very very
afraid yeah so the next chapter is the
moms and dads which speaking of very
very afraid it seems like a lot of the
moms and dads are too
yeah they're afraid they're afraid to
lose custody and these are you know the
parents who called me are overwhelmingly
political progressives they are
proud allies they've always been allies
but
um they their only sort of hesitation is
problem is they think
gosh this came out of nowhere i mean i
supported her when she said she was a
lesbian but now she's saying she's a boy
and she wants to have her breasts
removed i mean i'm not sure that's right
for her
and isn't couldn't she regret it these
are the most
sort of obvious questions there's
there's nothing
hateful about these questions but today
these parents are treated
like bigots they're isolated their
friends dropped them
and very often friends will go behind
their backs to send their daughters
encouragement by way of a binder the one
of those compression garments
or otherwise you know castigate them for
for bigotry allegedly what did this
teach you maybe or you're a parent
yourself i mean did this teach you
anything about
parenting in general and and setting
rules and being honest in the rest of it
sure i think one thing it taught me was
really how much we've over relied on
experts these so-called experts
who show up and claim to know more than
we do about our kids that we have spent
i don't know hundreds of thousands of
hours raising
and and i think that um i think that
trusting your own instincts about what's
right for your
daughter i mean if you in many cases
parents will call me
and they it just doesn't sit right with
them but they are being pressured by the
mental health establishment
or doctors to immediately agree with
their daughter and
fast track her to irreversible
consequences that she's likely to regret
so since you said the p word
progressives do you
sense that there is a connection between
sort of being politically progressive
and that it would end up in a situation
like this that you sort of just yes
everything goes all the time there is
nothing that's really
true per se and everything is sort of
how you feel that this was the
the obvious outcome of it in a weird way
well i think my my take is that the
reason
so many progressive families have have
fallen
into this and and let me say
conservative families have as well but
the reason it's it does seem to be
majority progressive families
is because they were less skeptical of
the culture
um conservatives have known for a long
time that social a social worker or a
psychologist
might not um treat their values with
respect
but liberals were genuinely taken aback
and completely caught off guard because
they thought wait a second i've been an
ally my entire life
this isn't about that it's about the
mental health of my daughter she's got
anxiety depression
shouldn't we look at those things first
and they were really assuming good
faith on behalf of um you know frankly
activists posing as doctors
yeah and we've just it seems to me that
that unfortunately for a lot of the
liberals and i think you know a little
bit about my story you know for a lot of
liberals until something like this hits
them
they think that there's there's nothing
wrong there that that it's just like oh
anything goes and then next thing you
know they're confronted with this and
then they feel a little bit differently
that's right they they describe
themselves now overwhelmingly as
politically homeless
and it's not because they feel
conservative um it's because they
they're really horrified that by the
assault on their
families i mean that that that all these
medical pro
these mental health professionals and
teachers would go behind their backs
to encourage their children to do
something that they think is harmful to
them
is is so stunning to them and it really
it does make them
really uh uncomfortable with with
progressive politics
yeah so did you have a sense or do you
have a sense that conservative parents
have some better mechanisms to fight
this either by standing up to the school
or
maybe dealing with the child a little
bit differently or whatever it might be
yeah it's interesting i think
conservative parents
were tended to be and and should be you
know
more skeptical of the culture they were
more skeptical
of these social workers and and and
psychologists who claim to know so much
about their parents
but they also look they're you know
their their default is that what do you
mean you're
suddenly a boy see sometimes progressive
parents were afraid to say that because
they don't want to be bigoted
but a conservative parent is it might be
more comfortable just saying what do you
mean you've been a girl your whole life
you're a girl i mean
just because you want a short haircut
doesn't suddenly make you a boy
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about women's
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our women's issues playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell